Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net Programming Throwdown, episode 35, Haskell. Take it away, Patrick. Welcome to another episode of Programming Throwdown, here late at night on the shores of Lake Michigan. You know, if we average one episode a month, we're close to the three-year mark. We used to do more than one episode a month, but now we've been pretty regular at once a month. Yeah, but then we had that break too, so I don't know. Yeah, I don't know what the average span is. I think we did 14 each in our first couple years years or something so i think we're actually on like the fourth calendar year that we've been doing this
本节目由 Host Tornado 提供。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net，Programming Throwdown 第 35 期，Haskell。Patrick，开始吧。欢迎收听新一期的 Programming Throwdown，现在是深夜，我们在密歇根湖畔。你知道，如果我们平均每月做一期节目，我们就快到三周年纪念日了。我们过去做的比每月一期多，但现在我们已经很规律地保持每月一期了。是的，但中间我们也休息过，所以我不知道。是的，我不知道平均跨度是多少。我想我们在前几年每年大概做了 14 期，所以我认为我们实际上是在做这个节目的第四个日历年。
or something man that's actually a co-worker of mine uh watched the or listened to the first episode and uh he was he was telling me oh i started using your tool of the show and i had no idea what he was talking about because it's been so long that was four years ago yes uh we we didn't even live in the same states that we do now so that's true it's a long time ago all right well first i want to start off with a shout out to the player fm team they sent us a nice email talking to us or showing us actually a picture of google io and they were demoing an application they made. You can check it out. That allows you to listen to podcasts.
或者类似的情况，伙计，其实我的一位同事看了或者听了第一期节目，他告诉我，哦，我开始用你们节目里提到的工具了，但我完全不知道他在说什么，因为那已经是四年前的事了，太久了。是的，我们甚至住的都不是现在所在的州，所以那是很久以前的事了。好吧，首先我要向 Player FM 团队致敬，他们给我们发了一封很棒的邮件，向我们展示了 Google I/O 的照片，他们正在演示他们制作的一个应用程序。你可以去看看。它允许你收听播客。
And they featured programming-related podcasts and specifically Programming Throwdown at Google I.O. So if you're at I.O. and you saw our picture, why did you not also send us that picture? That would have been cool. But anyways, some of you may be listening for the first time from that, although that was a little while ago, so you probably already listened. But thank you to the Player FM team for that honor. Yeah, definitely. We appreciate it. I was
他们在 Google I/O 上特别推荐了编程相关的播客，尤其是 Programming Throwdown。所以如果你在 I/O 现场看到了我们的照片，为什么不也发给我们呢？那会很酷。但不管怎样，你们中有些人可能是第一次因为那个而收听，尽管那已经是有一段时间了，所以你们可能已经听过了。但还是要感谢 Player FM 团队给予的这份荣誉。是的，绝对的。我们很感激。我当时
totally unexpected, and it was really a privilege to be at Google I.O. Do you care what your job title is? Yeah, I don't know. I mean, this is one of these tough questions. So I actually got asked this a few times. Once on Quora, somebody asked me to answer it. And then coincidentally, twice in real life, two different people asked me. And basically the gist of it is, you know,
完全没想到，能在 Google I/O 上出现真是一种荣幸。你在意你的职位头衔吗？是的，我不知道。我的意思是，这是一个棘手的问题。我实际上被问过几次。有一次在 Quora 上，有人让我回答这个问题。然后巧合的是，在现实生活中，有两个人也问过我。基本上它的要点是，你知道，
it comes along the same lines. Like, you know, I'm applying, you know, one company gave me job title X, the other company gave me job title Y. And it's not like one is, well, and so the idea there is, it's not like one is like chemist and the other is computer programmer, right? I mean, they're all kind of programming related it might just be one is like a senior and the other isn't or or you're like senior staff engineer at a company of four people but you're just regular engineer like a huge company you know and or you're data scientist for a software engineer and uh the reason why uh uh the reason I've heard of reasons why it actually does matter is for visa. It's kind of unexpected, but I have a colleague who's going for his, I guess they call it the E1A visa,
它属于同一类问题。就像，我在申请工作，一家公司给了我 X 头衔，另一家公司给了我 Y 头衔。这并不是说一个是，嗯，所以这里的想法是，这不像一个是化学家而另一个是程序员，对吧？我的意思是，它们都与编程有关，可能只是一个是高级工程师，而另一个不是，或者你在一家四人公司担任高级员工工程师，但在一家大公司你只是普通工程师，你知道，或者你是数据科学家还是软件工程师。我听说过它确实有影响的原因是签证。这有点出乎意料，但我有一位同事正在申请，我想他们称之为 E1A 签证，
which there's many different visas that you can get to work in the U.S., and the E1A stands for exceptional. And it's for people who have just a lot of publications or Nobel Prize, you know, people contributed to Nobel Prize, you know, projects or things like that. And so this person felt like, you know, getting the scientist title would sort of help his visa situation but you know outside of that i mean that could be true i'm personally of the mindset that it doesn't really matter but what's your take on it yeah i mean if you have well extenuating circumstances maybe sounds bad but uh yeah unless the visa thing i don't know anything about that but as a general rule for me personally no i don't think it matters um the problem is every company defines them differently and different companies have
美国有许多不同的工作签证，E1A 代表杰出人才。它是为那些拥有大量出版物或获得诺贝尔奖，你知道，为诺贝尔奖项目做出贡献的人准备的。所以这个人觉得，获得科学家的头衔可能会对他的签证情况有所帮助，但你知道，除此之外，我的意思是这可能是真的，我个人认为这并不重要，但你怎么看？是的，我的意思是，如果你有，嗯，情有可原的情况，听起来可能不太好，但除非是签证问题，否则我对此一无所知，但作为一般规则，我个人认为这并不重要。问题是每家公司对它们的定义都不同，不同的公司有
different expectations so if you're cto of a your own startup or you know ceo and cto of your own startup that means something different than if you're a cto of facebook um right so like they're not even in the same class and those are are obviously an extreme example. But being a senior engineer at one place or not senior engineer at another, you know, it just depends if it's a newer company versus a more legacy company, depending on what field it's in and, you know, what kind of mapping they do or want to be able to say we have this many senior software engineers working on something. Right. And they can skew and play games with it. And ultimately that's something that's actually really hard to find out before you accept a job at a company. It's not something that you're going to be able to ask a question like,
不同的期望，所以如果你是你自己初创公司的 CTO，或者你初创公司的 CEO 和 CTO，那和你作为 Facebook 的 CTO 的意义是不同的，对吧？所以它们甚至不在同一个档次，这些显然是极端的例子。但在一个地方担任高级工程师或在另一个地方不担任高级工程师，你知道，这取决于它是新公司还是老牌公司，取决于它所在的领域，以及你知道，他们做了什么样的映射，或者他们想说我们有多少高级软件工程师在做某事。对。他们可以歪曲并玩弄这些头衔。归根结底，在接受一家公司的工作之前，这真的很难发现。这不是你可以问的问题，比如，
what is the number of years of industry experience a person with this title typically has in your company? Right. They're going to be like, either that's not like that's personal or like like or protected to the company or they don't know and so it's really hard once you're in a company you have a feel but before you join a company i don't know i think you i don't know that has any correlation to your responsibility or your pay so the things that really show a company how much a company cares about you is
在你们公司，拥有这个头衔的人通常有多少年的行业经验？对。他们会说，这要么是私人的，要么是公司机密，或者他们也不知道，所以一旦你进入公司，你就会有感觉，但在加入公司之前，我不知道，我认为这与你的责任或薪水没有任何相关性。所以真正能体现公司有多在乎你的事情是
how much they offer you um and like the perks and the kinds of things and then what kind of role they describe having a vision for you and depending on the company that role may or may not be something you actually end up doing but um i think that's how a company so to play devil's advocate though right like if you if you have a higher title than, like, you know, if you're, let's say you're applying, let's say you want to change jobs, right? So the recruiter, you know, on day one, they don't have as much to go off of. If you're like, you know, really like senior staff software engineer versus if you're like level one software engineer the recruiter
他们给你提供多少薪水，以及福利和各种待遇，然后他们描述对你的愿景是什么样的角色，根据公司的不同，这个角色可能最终是你做的，也可能不是，但我认为这就是公司……但为了唱反调，对吧？如果你有一个更高的头衔，比如，假设你正在申请工作，你想换工作，对吧？所以招聘人员在第一天并没有太多依据。如果你是高级员工软件工程师，而对方是初级软件工程师，招聘人员
is going to kind of put you on a different path right i i don't i mean i guess it depends on sure maybe a bad recruiter no i mean you should because some places just have software engineer right like that's just it or especially if you work at a place that isn't a software engineering firm, right? Like, they mostly do something else. You may just be a software engineer. And you need, it's up to you to describe your role, right? Like, I manage a team or I'm an individual contributor or, and people always kind of lie on their resume a little. But I think part of the interview process should hopefully be them trying to figure
会把你放在不同的轨道上，对吧？我不知道，我想这取决于，当然，也许是一个糟糕的招聘人员。不，我的意思是你应该这样做，因为有些地方只有“软件工程师”这个头衔，对吧？或者特别是如果你在一家不是软件工程公司的公司工作，对吧？他们主要做别的事情。你可能只是一个软件工程师。你需要，这取决于你自己如何描述你的角色，对吧？比如，我管理一个团队，或者我是个人贡献者，或者，人们在简历上总是会撒一点谎。但我认为面试过程的一部分应该是他们试图弄清楚
out, like, what level of responsibility you have at your current company yeah that makes sense makes sense yeah i also agree that it doesn't it doesn't really matter i mean it sounds like this visa thing has some carry some weight because you know your your visa packet goes to somebody who probably knows nothing about the industry yeah you know whatever industry you're in um i would say so so that makes sense but yeah it doesn't matter but it does matter it does sound nice so why do you think it's a good title it sounds nice right like it it's like oh like i'm gonna get called a better title right like that's nice maybe it has that psychological like you know because you have a better title
你在当前公司承担的责任水平。是的，这很有道理。是的，我也同意这并不重要。我的意思是，听起来这个签证问题确实有分量，因为你知道，你的签证材料会交给一个可能对这个行业一无所知的人，无论你在什么行业，所以我认为确实如此，所以这很有道理。但它确实不重要，但它听起来确实不错，所以你为什么认为这是一个好头衔？它听起来不错，对吧？就像，哦，我要获得一个更好的头衔，那很好。也许它有那种心理暗示，你知道，因为你有一个更好的头衔，
you go in with like more brav. Yeah, I don't know. That could happen. I think it's just too complicated. It could go either way. So the variance of what it means is too high. Whether it means a little or a lot depends on so many things that you just can't weigh it properly. Yeah, that makes sense i mean i would think that some of the like larger companies probably have some kind of matrix where it's like okay if this person comes from intel and they have title x
你进去时会更有自信。是的，我不知道。这可能会发生。我认为这太复杂了。它可能朝任何方向发展。所以它所代表的含义差异太大。它意味着一点点还是很多，取决于太多的事情，你无法正确衡量它。是的，这很有道理。我的意思是，我想一些大公司可能有一些矩阵，比如，如果这个人来自英特尔，他们有 X 头衔，
and we'll like you know start off assuming that there'll be title y at microsoft or whatever you know there's probably that at the very like large scale so if you're going from one huge company to another but like uh yeah in general but why does it why do they care about and this goes back and It's probably that at the very large scale. So if you're going from one huge company to another. But like, yeah, in general. But why do they care about, and this goes back, and this isn't, you know, I don't think you should take a job just based on salary. But the reason that I've ever heard of recruiting or managers hiring people ever care about what level to place them is always because they're trying to get to a target salary. And typically, the salary you're able to put someone at is based on the position at your company. So by moving them up one title, you can give them more salary.
我们就会假设他们在微软或其他地方是 Y 头衔，你知道，在大规模招聘时可能确实有这种情况。所以如果你从一家大公司跳槽到另一家大公司。但总的来说，为什么他们关心这个？这又回到了……在大规模招聘时可能确实有这种情况。所以如果你从一家大公司跳槽到另一家大公司。但总的来说，为什么他们关心这个？这又回到了……我不认为你应该仅仅根据薪水找工作。但我听说过招聘人员或经理关心将人放在什么级别，总是因为他们试图达到目标薪水。通常，你能给某人定的薪水是基于你在公司的职位。所以通过提升他们的头衔，你可以给他们更高的薪水。
And so the only reason they've ever wanted to move people up is because they want to make them a more competitive offer, not because they thought they were a more skilled worker. But that's dependent on the company. So that's why I said the actual revealing bit of information is your salary offer not the title but then on the flip side right if you don't reveal your salary when you're negotiating your future job then they still have your title unless you don't reveal that either yeah so i guess like they could try to infer your current salary from your title but then maybe that just means you should't reveal that either that's true yeah so i guess like they could try to infer your current
所以他们想提升人们职位的唯一原因是因为他们想提供更有竞争力的报价，而不是因为他们认为他们是技术更强的员工。但这取决于公司。这就是为什么我说真正揭示信息的是你的薪水报价，而不是头衔。但另一方面，如果你在协商未来工作时不透露你的薪水，他们仍然有你的头衔，除非你也不透露那个。是的，所以我猜他们可能会试图从你的头衔推断你目前的薪水，但那可能意味着你不应该透露那个。那是真的。是的，所以我猜他们可能会试图从你的头衔推断你目前的
salary from your title but then maybe that just means you should never reveal either yeah you probably shouldn't reveal either i think we talked about this in the actually you know we had an interviewing show but we never had a salary negotiation show that's a that sounds like a stressful show yeah that that would be that would uh that would stress me out i don't want to give people advice there so i i watched i managed to watch the final game i tuned in just at the right time to watch the conclusion of the international which sounds like a movie but it's actually the dota defense defense of the asians ancients defense of the ancients i think that's what it stands for yeah valve a game video game we're talking about video games by valve uh and the world champions or what ship is called the international
薪水，但那可能意味着你不应该透露任何一个。是的，你可能都不应该透露。我想我们在面试节目中谈过这个，但我们从来没有做过薪水谈判的节目。那听起来是一个压力很大的节目。是的，那会让我感到压力。我不想给人们建议。所以我看了，我设法看了决赛。我正好在正确的时间调入，观看了《国际邀请赛》的结局，这听起来像是一部电影，但实际上它是 Dota，Defense of the Ancients（远古遗迹守卫），我想这就是它的缩写。是的，Valve 的一款电子游戏，我们正在谈论 Valve 的电子游戏，世界冠军赛，或者叫国际邀请赛。
and it made a bunch of press this year because um the prize pool was 10 million dollars and i think the winning team got just over five million dollars and there's five people on a team so it became instant millionaires each which is pretty cool um and one interesting thing is that uh valve didn't put in the prize pool themselves people bought items in game in order to increase the prize pool for the other competitors yeah this is totally genius so valve came out with dota defense of the ancients 2 or dota 2 and they had a you know they didn't want to unbalance the game like there's a game that came out called battlefield heroes uh where you could uh it was free to play but you could buy like a better gun or whatever right and and it wasn't very popular it was reasonably popular but wasn't that popular and and the big thing is you know the more competitive you are and and most
它今年引起了很多媒体关注，因为奖金池是 1000 万美元，我想获胜的队伍获得了超过 500 万美元，一个队有五个人，所以每个人瞬间成了百万富翁，这很酷。一个有趣的事情是，Valve 自己并没有投入奖金池，人们购买游戏内物品来增加其他竞争者的奖金池。是的，这简直是天才。所以 Valve 推出了 Dota 2，他们不想破坏游戏的平衡，就像有一款叫《战地英雄》的游戏，它是免费玩的，但你可以买更好的枪之类的，它不是很受欢迎，虽然还算受欢迎，但没那么火。最重要的是，你越有竞争力，大多数
people who play dota 2 are just have a competitive nature uh the more like you don't want things that you don't want money to influence the game pay to win yeah exactly pay to win that's right but uh so what these guys did is they took a page out of the korean mmo handbook and said okay we're just gonna sell like funny hats and sweatshirts and weapons that don't actually do damage like any more than those different looks and so just yeah we'll sell looks and i remember kind of thinking this is ridiculous and i remember thinking like okay one of these days i'll spend you know some money and buy a hat just because i like the game but uh it ended up not happening but then what they did was
玩 Dota 2 的人都有竞争天性，你越不希望金钱影响游戏，付费获胜。是的，完全正确，付费获胜。但他们所做的是借鉴了韩国 MMO 的手册，说好吧，我们只卖有趣的帽子、运动衫和武器，它们不会造成比其他外观更多的伤害，所以我们只卖外观。我记得当时觉得这很荒谬，我记得当时想，好吧，总有一天我会花点钱买顶帽子，因为我喜欢这个游戏，但最终没买。但后来他们做的是
they added this um this donation thing so now it's like not only. But then what they did was they added this donation thing. So now it's like not only is there a donation aspect of it where part of it will go to these top-notch players, but then also they added an achievement kind of system. The point is they finally hit the formula on how to get money from people without affecting the game yeah and there was something more complicated too like i think as they cross certain like almost like a kickstarter campaign as well like as if you bought it and then enough other people bought it you got
他们增加了这个捐赠功能，所以现在不仅如此。但后来他们做的是，他们增加了这个捐赠功能。所以现在不仅有捐赠方面的内容，其中一部分会给这些顶尖玩家，而且他们还增加了一种成就系统。重点是他们终于找到了如何在不影响游戏的情况下从人们那里赚钱的公式。是的，还有更复杂的事情，我想当他们跨越某些门槛时，就像 Kickstarter 活动一样，如果你买了它，然后足够多的人也买了它，你就会从购买中获得
more benefit from having bought it or whatever yeah there's a pyramid scheme basically yeah not exactly yeah something like that was more complicated anyways but whatever got a lot of press attention for them i wonder how many new people like played the game i mean i never i'd heard the game i've never played it still haven't played it but i actually know how it's played now uh versus i didn't and they had a bunch of simultaneous streams going so like you know different languages but then also like if you've never played the game like a new and it's confusing because the team that won is called newbie oh spoiler alert um but then they had a newbie channel like a new player channel which like if you've never played before instead
更多的好处之类的。是的，基本上是传销。是的，不完全是，但类似的东西更复杂。不管怎样，这为他们赢得了大量的媒体关注。我想知道有多少新玩家玩了这个游戏。我的意思是，我听说过这个游戏，但我从来没玩过，现在还没玩过，但我现在知道它是怎么玩的了。他们有许多同步直播，比如不同的语言，但如果你从来没玩过这个游戏，它会让人困惑，因为获胜的队伍叫 Newbie（菜鸟），哦，剧透预警。但他们有一个新手频道，一个新玩家频道，如果你以前从未玩过，
of just using the weird acronyms and slang they would try to explain what was going on um which of course it was still happening in real time so they didn't fall behind which made it hard like okay hang on we'll come back to that because this is what's happening now but yeah i thought that was nice and it was cool to watch a video game we actually had real announcers they had like fireworks when the team finally won uh you know and um it was really you know i i can't say that i'm a big fan of watching video games i've never really watched them before like live or anything but um you know it was kind of interesting to watch you know i'll try it i've never watched video games live either but uh but i've been hearing a lot about it is it still going on
而不是使用奇怪的缩写和俚语，他们会试图解释发生了什么。当然，这仍然是实时发生的，所以他们没有落后，这使得它很难，比如，好吧，等一下，我们会回到那个，因为这是现在正在发生的事情。但是的，我觉得这很好，看电子游戏很酷。他们有真正的播音员，当队伍最终获胜时他们有烟花，你知道，这真的，我不能说我是看电子游戏的大粉丝，我以前从未真正看过它们，比如直播之类的，但你知道，看这个很有趣。我会试试的，我也从来没看过电子游戏直播，但我听说了不少，它还在进行吗？
so it's done i think league of legends is currently in some sort of tournament now which is the other big moba but um this one is done the team won a team new team newbie from china um when i think actually two teams from china were in the um finals and yeah so the thing was that you know you watch it and because this game is actually really quite complicated and hard to explain and very fast like your actions per minute really matter um it makes it for a little bit of a weird thing so like this attack happens and just kind of like finishes very quickly it's like you kind of don't know what happened uh and they also it's you know a big map and they move around the map very quickly to show you different things happening in different places so it's it was a little hard to watch it wasn't as nice as say you know watching a football game or a basketball game where there's nice breaks
所以它结束了。我想《英雄联盟》目前正在进行某种锦标赛，这是另一个大型 MOBA 游戏，但这个已经结束了。来自中国的队伍，新队伍 Newbie 赢了。我想决赛中有两支中国队伍。所以事情是这样的，你看着它，因为这个游戏实际上非常复杂，很难解释，而且非常快，你的每分钟操作数（APM）真的很重要，这让它变得有点奇怪。所以这次攻击发生并很快结束，你有点不知道发生了什么。而且它是一个大地图，他们移动得非常快，向你展示在不同地方发生的不同事情，所以看它有点难。它不像看足球比赛或篮球比赛那样好，那里有很好的休息时间
in the action where they can show you an instant replay and yeah and there's only one ball and only one really center of action and yeah this is just kind of crazy wow yeah i'll have to check this i'm sure i can watch uh archive oh i'm sure yeah yeah yeah yeah um but i was you know i was on i watched some of it on twitch. is it twitch.tv i don't know on twitch oh yeah twitch is yeah so it was actually really cool and it was crazy to see the number of people watching like when i tuned in you know towards the end there was on just the stream i was on which was like the mainstream whatever i think i want to say there was up up to almost like 300 000 people watching it simultaneously like when i was watching oh my god um and that was just one channel that was live it was like middle of the day west coast time i don't
在动作中，他们可以给你看即时回放，而且只有一个球，只有一个真正的动作中心。这简直太疯狂了。哇，是的，我得去看看。我相信我可以看存档。哦，我相信。但我是在 Twitch 上看了一些。是 twitch.tv 吗？我不知道，在 Twitch 上。哦，是的，Twitch 是的。所以它实际上真的很酷，看到观看人数很疯狂，当我调入时，你知道在最后，我看的那个流，也就是主流什么的，我想说有近 30 万人同时在观看，当我观看时。天哪，那只是一个直播频道。那是西海岸时间中午，我不知道
know what time it was other parts of the world um but yeah that was like one game one channel one time like that's actually you know it's not a football game can probably generate you know millions and millions of views even for a non-championship game but still like 300 000 is a lot of people to just watch a video game right like yeah i would argue most football games that aren't playoff games won't have that kind of attendance i think i mean that's hard to say because some football stadiums are like oh like 100 000 almost 100 000 people in them just live yeah but that's a third of think i mean that's hard to say because some football stadiums are like oh like a hundred thousand almost a hundred thousand people in them just live yeah but that's a third of yeah i guess that's true but the uh um the other thing uh that i was gonna say is twitch tv is is actually amazing like right now they're focused on games but i don't really see why twitch
世界其他地方是什么时间，但那是一场比赛，一个频道，一个时间。这实际上，你知道，它不是一场足球比赛，可能即使是非冠军赛也能产生数百万的观看量，但 30 万人观看电子游戏仍然很多，对吧？是的，我会说大多数不是季后赛的足球比赛都不会有那种上座率。我想，我的意思是这很难说，因为有些足球场有 10 万人，几乎 10 万人在现场。是的，但那是三分之一的……我想这很难说，因为有些足球场有 10 万人，几乎 10 万人在现场。是的，但那是三分之一的……是的，我想那是真的。但另一件事，我想说的是 Twitch TV 实际上很棒。现在他们专注于游戏，但我真的看不出为什么 Twitch
tv can't just do anything like anytime someone wants to stream anything you know like twitch tv could could do that i mean like i i think it's just a matter of time before they branch out to just doing streaming video for everyone yeah it seems really popular with the uh certain groups of people but yeah check it out yeah i guess it's true it's like they have a good niche uh but it just seems like i mean everyone should just uh i guess there aren't that many things though that you would stream right because like you you still have to be on your home internet unless they support cell phone i mean i think this is a big market already for them like between you know these these battle games like minecraft has a lot of live streaming i saw people streaming even like
TV 不能做任何事情，比如任何时候有人想直播任何东西，你知道，Twitch TV 都可以做到。我的意思是，我认为他们扩展到为每个人直播视频只是时间问题。是的，它在某些群体中似乎非常受欢迎，但去看看吧。是的，我想这是真的，就像他们有一个很好的利基市场，但看起来每个人都应该，我猜没有那么多东西可以直播，对吧？因为你仍然必须在你的家庭网络上，除非他们支持手机。我的意思是，我认为这已经是一个很大的市场了，在这些战斗游戏之间，比如《我的世界》有很多直播，我看到人们甚至在直播
the world of warcraft card game uh what is it hearthstone oh yeah i've been playing that a little on my ipad i should have made that my tool yeah it's pretty fun um i've been playing it on the ipad as well yeah so i really like that game um and there's people who live stream playing that game i think i guess from their pc um right but yeah it's like people stream what i would consider maybe strange stuff but uh yeah i mean i would love to live stream my hikes like like just strap a cell phone in my arm or something or my head oh yeah that's right yeah maybe google glass will uh will do but google glass doesn't do streaming right i mean they do hangouts yeah you can do a hangout don't do but but that's different right this is like like i don't think you can have a thousand people in your hangouts on air man
《魔兽世界》卡牌游戏，是什么来着？《炉石传说》。哦，是的，我在 iPad 上玩了一点，我应该把它作为我的工具。是的，它很有趣。我也在 iPad 上玩它。所以我真的很喜欢那个游戏。有人直播玩那个游戏，我想我猜是从他们的电脑上。对，但人们直播我可能认为是奇怪的东西。但我很乐意直播我的徒步旅行，比如把手机绑在手臂上或头上。哦，是的，没错。也许 Google Glass 会做，但 Google Glass 不支持直播，对吧？我的意思是他们有 Hangouts，你可以做一个 Hangout，但那是不一样的，对吧？这就像，我不认为你的 Hangouts on Air 能有 1000 人。
that's what people stream to youtube but i don't know if you can do that for me i have no idea oh anyways it's just software man just software all right all right it's just software next time yeah next time so there's uh so typescript which is actually, we talked about this before the show, we're going to definitely do an episode on all of these JavaScript compiled to JavaScript languages like TypeScript and CoffeeScript and things like that. But there's a short story on this is, the JavaScript VM is the only VM that's in all popular browsers. And so if you want to write code that works on someone else's computer, which it's most likely going to run on their browser, and so it's most likely going to be in JavaScript. With that said, JavaScript isn't really designed for writing like very complex, or let me just step back javascript is one language and as we know from watching this from listening to this show uh you know there's many different
那是人们直播到 YouTube 的方式，但我不知道你能不能为我做那个，我不知道。哦，不管怎样，这只是软件，伙计，只是软件。好吧，好吧，这只是软件。下次吧。是的，下次。所以有 TypeScript，我们之前在节目中谈过这个，我们肯定会做一期关于所有这些编译成 JavaScript 的语言的节目，比如 TypeScript 和 CoffeeScript 之类的。但这里有一个简短的故事，JavaScript VM 是所有流行浏览器中唯一的 VM。所以如果你想编写在别人电脑上运行的代码，它很可能在他们的浏览器上运行，所以它很可能必须是 JavaScript。话虽如此，JavaScript 并不是真正为编写非常复杂的代码而设计的，或者让我退一步，JavaScript 是一种语言，正如我们从收听这个节目所知道的那样，你知道，有很多不同的
languages and each one kind of serves their purpose so uh you'd like to do other languages but you have javascript so there's a lot of these languages such as typescript which compile to javascript so you can write in something, but still run on other people's browsers. And TypeScript is actually made by Microsoft. Actually, it was made by a company that was bought by Microsoft. But the compiler has been open sourced, but it really hasn't built a lot of community around it. And now there's CoffeeScript, and there's other competitors that are pretty good.
语言，每一种都有其用途。所以你喜欢使用其他语言，但你有 JavaScript。所以有很多这样的语言，比如 TypeScript，它们编译成 JavaScript，这样你就可以用某种语言编写，但仍然可以在别人的浏览器上运行。TypeScript 实际上是由微软制造的。实际上，它是由一家被微软收购的公司制造的。但编译器已经开源了，但它并没有围绕它建立起很大的社区。现在有 CoffeeScript，还有其他相当不错的竞争对手。
So they decided to move to GitHub to get sort of that community aspect of GitHub, and they rewrote the compiler, which is pretty cool. It's got a lot of improvements. But in general, GitHub is another one of those things, like Twitch TV, that has just really amazed me at how it's just kind of changed the whole ecosystem of programming. It's like the Craigslist of source control.
所以他们决定搬到 GitHub 以获得那种 GitHub 的社区氛围，并且他们重写了编译器，这很酷。它有很多改进。但总的来说，GitHub 是像 Twitch TV 那样的东西之一，它让我非常惊讶，它是如何改变了整个编程生态系统的。它就像源代码控制界的 Craigslist。
Like the Craig? Let me think about that. I don't know what that means. I just thought it sounded really deep. It did sound deep. Yeah, I can't quite comprehend that. No, just because everybody says, like, Craigslist killed the newspaper classifieds, which is where newspapers made a lot of their money and so like github like kind of killed like a lot of people trying to charge for
像 Craigslist？让我考虑一下。我不知道那意味着什么。我只是觉得它听起来很深刻。它确实听起来很深刻。是的，我无法完全理解这一点。不，只是因为每个人都说，比如，Craigslist 杀死了报纸分类广告，那是报纸赚取大部分钱的地方，所以 GitHub 就像杀死了很多人试图收费
essentially the same service that's not really a good analogy because it didn't really it mostly just made it better as opposed to doing the same thing cheaper terrible analogy i'm sorry i apologize the thing github did that that that i think really is what took them to the top is the way that different users could interact with each other's branches, like with each other's repositories. The idea that somebody could create a branch of my repository and then ask me to merge it back in. That was, in my opinion like the big
本质上是同样的服务。那不是一个很好的类比，因为它并没有真正做到，它主要是让它变得更好，而不是以更便宜的价格做同样的事情。糟糕的类比，对不起，我道歉。GitHub 所做的我认为真正让他们登上顶峰的事情是不同用户可以与彼此的分支交互的方式，比如与彼此的存储库交互。有人可以创建我的存储库的一个分支，然后要求我将其合并回去。在我看来，那是
innovation there like i i uh put hyper neat which is my phd dissertation source code on uh github and it has like a ton of forks and somebody went off and made like an arcade or sorry an atari like uh emulator AI. And a ton of crazy things have been forked from it. And I can actually go back and look at what's been forked, even though I don't know any of those people. I think that that is something pretty amazing that GitHub did. I'm a terrible person. I've been using Git recently.
那里的重大创新。我把 HyperNEAT，也就是我的博士论文源代码，放在了 GitHub 上，它有很多分支，有人去制作了一个类似街机的，或者抱歉，类似 Atari 的 AI 模拟器。从它那里分支出去了很多疯狂的东西。我实际上可以回去看看分支出去了什么，即使我不认识那些人。我认为这是 GitHub 所做的非常了不起的事情。我是一个糟糕的人。我最近一直在使用 Git。
I've been trying to learn it more. It's just not clicking with me i've just not found the right explanation or way to grok it in my head and i just nothing nothing but git but git itself it's just not like it does not mesh with my way i've been doing source control so i since i didn't start off doing it i'm trying to figure out like how to adapt and i think that's the wrong approach and so i've i gotta work it but right now you know i'm not impressed i don't i don't care for yeah so git it took me a long time also to learn git and i kind of uh thought that git was just it was just kind of ridiculous and it didn't make sense for a long time one of the a couple of
我一直在尝试更多地学习它。它就是没法让我产生共鸣，我还没找到正确的解释或方式来理解它，我什么都没有，只有 Git，但 Git 本身就是……它与我做源代码控制的方式不匹配。所以我从一开始就没用过它，我正在尝试弄清楚如何适应，我认为这是错误的方法，所以我必须努力，但现在你知道，我印象不深，我不关心。是的，所以 Git，我也花了很多时间才学会 Git，我曾经认为 Git 只是有点荒谬，很长一段时间都说不通。其中一个
things that really helped me early on was git stash i don't know if you've used that but but yeah like i so i used to think that like you had to just commit all your changes before you could switch branches and that was kind of frustrating because i'd have two branches that were halfway done and i couldn't figure out how to switch but git stash lets you do that and you'd also stash and then update a branch and then unstash and it kind of so i should correct git works fine for me locally but you know ultimately your the idea of git is to like share with other people that and that's where it starts to fall down for me i start to have problems
真正帮助我早期的东西是 git stash，我不知道你是否用过它，但是的，我曾经认为你必须在切换分支之前提交所有更改，这很令人沮丧，因为我有两个分支只做了一半，我不知道如何切换。但 git stash 让你做到这一点，你也可以 stash，然后更新一个分支，然后 unstash，它有点……所以我应该纠正一下，Git 在本地对我来说工作得很好，但归根结底，Git 的想法是与其他人分享，而这正是它对我来说开始失败的地方，我开始遇到问题。
um oh yeah but maybe it's specifically the collaboration tools that that the team i'm on has been using but yeah the that's possible. Anyways. Yeah. Mesh networks are pretty cool. And I read an article about, I don't know. I'm trying to say deep things. I don't know if it's working. Mesh networks are meshy. Totally.
嗯，哦，是的，但这可能是因为我所在的团队一直在使用协作工具，但是的，这有可能。不管怎样。是的，网状网络很酷。我读了一篇关于……的文章，我不知道。我试图说深刻的话。我不知道它是否有效。网状网络是网状的。完全正确。
Mesh like a sieve. This guy's wearing a pink shirt. Oakland. This guy's wearing a pink shirt and his name is Valentine. That should make you look at this. Okay. So Oakland is a city near where Jason and I live
像筛子一样。这家伙穿着粉红色的衬衫。奥克兰。这家伙穿着粉红色的衬衫，他的名字叫 Valentine。那应该让你看看这个。好吧。所以奥克兰是 Jason 和我住的地方附近的一个城市，
sort of in the Bay Area of California near San Francisco and it's known for its San Francisco it's known to be kind of quirky and Oakland is even more quirky I don't know the right is that true wow I did not know that yeah so Oakland. So you hear a lot about like protests and stuff from Oakland and in a similar vein, I guess. One of the things that Oakland. So they've had some problems with trying to organize awareness events, let's call them. And the various authorities deciding to like shut down cell towers or Wi-Fi connectivity. And this has been a continuing problem for them. And also being near such tech-minded people,
有点在加州的湾区，靠近旧金山，它以旧金山而闻名，它以有点古怪而闻名，而奥克兰甚至更古怪。我不知道对不对，那是真的吗？哇，我不知道。是的，所以奥克兰。所以你听说了很多关于奥克兰的抗议活动之类的，我想在类似的脉络下。奥克兰的一件事。所以他们在试图组织意识活动时遇到了一些问题，我们称之为意识活动。而各级当局决定关闭手机信号塔或 Wi-Fi 连接。这对他们来说一直是一个持续的问题。而且由于靠近这些有技术头脑的人，
they've decided that internet is a basic right and that they would like to have uninterrupted network connections. So they've decided to build a mesh network, both to provide kind of guaranteed access and also to get around any potential censorship. So trying to avoid if someone decides to censor something, try to get around it.
他们决定互联网是一项基本权利，他们希望拥有不间断的网络连接。所以他们决定建立一个网状网络，既是为了提供某种保证的访问，也是为了绕过任何潜在的审查。所以试图避免如果有人决定审查某事，试图绕过它。
And so it's basically just about a group of people trying to work against the man to build a mesh network. But it's kind of interesting. And they're talking about, I guess, the group of people trying to establish this in Oakland studied one that was used in New York State when a hurricane hit and did a pretty good job surviving. It actually was used for some of the people right after the hurricane, and it was the only form of connectivity it had, even when cell towers and stuff were down. And so that is a great idea.
所以这基本上就是一群人试图对抗体制来建立一个网状网络。但这很有趣。他们正在谈论，我猜，试图在奥克兰建立这个的群体研究了一个在飓风袭击纽约州时使用的网络，并且在生存方面做得很好。它实际上在飓风过后被一些人使用，即使在手机信号塔之类的东西倒塌时，它也是他们拥有的唯一连接形式。所以这是一个伟大的想法。
People always say about ham radio operators and how it's really useful to be a ham radio operator right after an emergency and how much help you can be. And this is also something that I think would be great to get involved with, even if you don't really agree with the dissident nature of it, perhaps, or like, a hurricane, what it may be, making sure that people have another way of getting on that isn't controlled by kind of just a couple people and maybe at risk to single-point failures. Yeah, that makes sense. I remember there was a lot of research on mesh networks and all sorts of graph theory and what's the lowest power way to get internet to everybody
人们总是谈论业余无线电操作员，以及在紧急情况后成为业余无线电操作员是多么有用，以及你能提供多大的帮助。这也是我认为值得参与的事情，即使你可能并不真正同意它的异见性质，或者，飓风，无论它可能是什么，确保人们有另一种方式上网，而不是由几个人控制，并且可能面临单点故障的风险。是的，这很有道理。我记得关于网状网络和各种图论，以及让每个人都能上网的最省电方式有很多研究，
and all of that and uh yeah but i didn't see too much beyond that so it's cool that someone's actually building a real one instead of just theorizing all right so my article is on uh oh no good you're good uh sorry my article is on the raspberry pi basically there's a new version of the raspberry pi and uh it's pretty cool i actually have never owned a raspberry pi but um i did have a gumsticks which is kind of a similar idea uh but it was kind of a little bit more niche i think raspberry pi is much more mainstream i think it was going to be niche but it hit mainstream or maybe it wasn't it was like the first thing to end up becoming mainstream yeah that's right it's definitely mainstream by accident because they have such a huge backlog or maybe maybe people did it on purpose right like people always intend
所有这些，是的，但我没看到太多除此之外的东西。所以有人真的在建造一个真正的网络而不是仅仅进行理论研究，这很酷。好吧，所以我的文章是关于……哦，不，你很好，抱歉，我的文章是关于 Raspberry Pi 的，基本上有一个新版本的 Raspberry Pi，它很酷。我实际上从来没有拥有过 Raspberry Pi，但我确实有一个 Gumstix，这是一种类似的想法，但它有点更小众，我认为 Raspberry Pi 更主流。我认为它本来会是小众的，但它变得主流了，或者也许它不是，它是第一个最终变得主流的东西。是的，没错。它绝对是偶然变得主流的，因为他们有巨大的积压，或者也许人们是故意这样做的，对吧？就像人们总是打算
to be mainstream it just never works out maybe yeah um um but yeah so check it out if you're a raspberry pi fan this one has a bunch of it fixed a lot of nits people were having i also don't own one but i keep telling myself i'm gonna get one and then i'm gonna have all these projects to use it for but i never quite have like oh i'm ready to start this project that needs it and order it and so i've just i don't want to just buy one and have it sit around i have too much of that kind of stuff yeah that's the thing like i hit my critical mass of things that just sit around and collecting dust so including me yeah i sit around already collect dust yeah all right time for book of the show my book of the show is start with y by simon sinek so i actually uh was got back into watching
变得主流，它只是从来没有成功过。也许吧。嗯，所以如果你是 Raspberry Pi 的粉丝，去看看吧。这个版本修复了人们遇到的一堆小毛病。我也没有，但我一直告诉自己我要买一个，然后我会用它做所有这些项目，但我从来没有像“哦，我准备好开始这个需要它的项目了”那样，然后订购它。所以我只是……我不想只是买一个让它放在那里。我有太多那种东西了。是的，就是这样，我达到了我拥有的东西的临界质量，它们只是放在那里积灰，包括我。是的，我已经坐在那里积灰了。好吧，是时候介绍本期图书了。我的本期图书是 Simon Sinek 的《从为什么开始》（Start with Why）。我实际上又开始看
ted talks um which is pretty epic i just love them them. And I can't believe it's been so long since I saw them. Actually, TED Talks were kind of on the decline in the sense that, well, they started the TEDx, like the franchise TED Talks. And then they started in the stream, like, mingling the TED with the TEDx Talks. And so the quality basically went down. Yeah, I stopped watching because it was like most of these are not good yeah I mean I watched like 10 talks in a row from TEDx women and I mean you know women are great uh they make up half of the world and they have a lot of great things to say but like TEDx women was geared for like a specific genre of talk it was it was a lot about like feminism and things like
TED 演讲了，这非常棒，我只是喜欢它们。我不敢相信我这么久没看它们了。实际上，TED 演讲在某种意义上一直在走下坡路，因为，好吧，他们开始了 TEDx，就像 TED 演讲的特许经营权。然后他们开始在流媒体中，将 TED 和 TEDx 演讲混在一起。所以质量基本上下降了。是的，我停止观看了，因为大多数这些都不好。是的，我的意思是，我连续看了 10 个来自 TEDx Women 的演讲，我的意思是，你知道，女性很棒，她们占世界的一半，她们有很多伟大的事情要说，但 TEDx Women 是针对特定类型的演讲，它有很多关于女权主义和类似的事情，
that and and it was just it was too niche right and to get and i got 10 in a row of those and i was like okay you know i'm kind of done and so uh they started doing that but now they're back um you know the the past like 10 or 11 ted talks on on the YouTube stream have all been from the main TED conference. And they've been amazing. I'll have to check it out. And one of them was from Simon Sinek. I was so impressed with his talk, I got his book and I've been going through it. Wait, like Dead Tree version?
而且它太小众了，我连续看了 10 个，我就想，好吧，你知道，我有点受够了。所以他们开始那样做，但现在他们回来了。你知道，YouTube 流上的过去 10 或 11 个 TED 演讲都来自主要的 TED 会议。它们非常棒。我得去看看。其中一个是 Simon Sinek 的。我对他的演讲印象深刻，我买了这本书，我一直在读它。等等，是纸质书版本吗？
No, I got the Kindle version. Yeah, so I'm saving saving some trees hurting some bits those bits are like just burning at the stake um so basically the book is about uh um different companies and actually it really kind of uh covers this idea of company culture and sort of what that means and and how to sort of have a strong culture like internally and externally and it has a bunch of great examples it goes over a variety of different companies but but one of the things to really take away is this they say you know when you're
不，我买了 Kindle 版本。是的，所以我正在拯救一些树，伤害一些比特。那些比特就像在火刑柱上燃烧一样。所以基本上这本书是关于不同的公司，实际上它确实涵盖了公司文化这个想法，以及这意味着什么，以及如何在内部和外部拥有强大的文化。它有很多很棒的例子，它涵盖了各种不同的公司，但真正要带走的一件事是这个，他们说，你知道，当你……
pitching something don't start with what They say like companies that start with what end up becoming commodities. So for example, if you say we're Intel, we make a processor that's, you know, 1.2 times as fast, you know, it's 20% faster than the other processor. So if you start with what, you become a commodity, like you're only as good as your 20 improvement and if the other company comes with like a 30 improvement then people just go with that right but if you start with why like uh uh you know let me think of let me pick on a company here um tesla like uh tesla we believe and i don't know what tesla. I'm just making this up, right? But it's like, Tesla, you know, nobody should have to, you know, put fuel in their tank again.
推销某样东西时，不要从“是什么”开始。那些从“是什么”开始的公司，最终往往会沦为大路货。举个例子，如果你说“我们是英特尔，我们制造的处理器速度快了1.2倍，也就是比其他处理器快20%”。如果你从“是什么”开始，你就会变得平庸，因为你的价值仅限于那20%的提升；如果另一家公司带来了30%的提升，人们就会转投他们。但如果你从“为什么”开始，比如……让我想想，拿哪家公司举例呢……特斯拉。特斯拉，我们相信……我不知道特斯拉的理念是什么，我只是随口一说，但大概是：特斯拉，没人应该再需要往油箱里加油了。
Or Tesla, like, why are we... Saving the world, one tank at a time. Yeah, but it's not only about... So saving the world is also a what, right? So you have to ask, like, why save the world? Wait, you have to say why save the world is also a what, right? So you have to ask, like, why save the world? Wait, you have to say why save the world? Yeah, of course. Or more specifically, why, you know, why what Tesla is doing is saving the world more than other things.
或者特斯拉，为什么我们要……一次加满一箱油，拯救世界。是的，但这不仅仅是关于……所以“拯救世界”也是一个“是什么”，对吧？所以你必须问，为什么要拯救世界？等等，你得说为什么拯救世界也是一个“是什么”，对吧？所以你必须问，为什么要拯救世界？等等，你得说为什么要拯救世界？是的，当然。或者更具体地说，为什么特斯拉所做的事情比其他事情更能拯救世界。
You know what I mean? I'm going to watch this talk. I'm intrigued. Yeah, I'm not doing a good job because i'm not simon sinek and and the reason why i like this book so much is because it's uh it really he does an amazing job explaining something that is pretty innate and biological and he actually goes into biology and chemistry of the brain and things like that and he's done a lot of research and he explains something which is uh you know like you often like get these kind of feelings like i remember
你明白我的意思吗？我要去看看这个演讲，我很有兴趣。是的，我讲得不太好，因为我不是西蒙·斯涅克。我之所以这么喜欢这本书，是因为他非常出色地解释了一些相当内在和生物学层面的东西。他实际上深入探讨了大脑的生物学和化学机制之类的东西，他做了大量的研究，并解释了一些……你知道，就像你经常会有那种感觉，我记得
when i got my first ipod um the way that you could endlessly scroll through your music because it had the wheel right the little touch sensitive wheel and instead of having instead of having a like the the zoom had the thing that you slid with your thumb and you had to bring your thumb back to the starting position and slide it again but the idea that you could just slide forever with your thumb there's something kind of innately
当我拿到第一个iPod时，那种你可以无休止地滚动浏览音乐的方式，因为它有那个转盘，那个触控转盘。而不是像之前的设备那样，你得用拇指滑动，滑完还得把拇指移回起始位置再滑一次。但那种可以用拇指无限滑动的想法，有一种天生的
cool about that. It's sort of like when you watch Plinko in The Price is Right there's some neurons that fire and you get a kick out of watching the little disc bounce on those pegs. We are totally like so deep in analogy in this in this show. Yeah, I've gone too far. Saving the world is like a Plinko board.
酷劲。这有点像你在看《价格猜猜猜》里的Plinko游戏，当小圆盘在钉子上弹跳时，你大脑里的一些神经元会受到刺激，你会从中获得快感。我们在这个节目里真是陷入类比陷阱太深了。是的，我扯得太远了。拯救世界就像一个Plinko游戏板。
Yeah, but there's there's many of these things where they're innate to our biology. Like we get a kick out of it and we don't really know why. It's not a logical thing. And he goes into a lot of that when he talks about sort of how to both sell a company and how to build identity at a company or at any type of
是的，有很多这类东西是我们的生物本能。我们从中获得快感，却不知道为什么。这不是逻辑问题。他在谈论如何销售一家公司，以及如何在公司、组织、家庭或任何其他团体中建立认同感时，深入探讨了这一点。我才读了一半，所以还有不少要读。但我印象非常深刻。绝对的，如果你不……我才读了一半，所以还有不少要读。但我印象非常深刻。绝对的，如果你不想读这本书，至少去看看……等等，你还没看到结局？不知道结局你不能推荐它。他有两个
organization or family or what have you. And I'm only about halfway through it, so I still have quite a bit to read. But I'm very impressed. And definitely, if you don'm only about halfway through it, so I still have quite a bit to read. But I'm very impressed. And definitely, if you don't want to read the book, at least check out... Wait, so you don't know the ending yet? You can't recommend it without knowing the ending. He has two
TED演讲，都很棒。所以，TED演讲总共也就40分钟左右，而读完这本书需要几个小时。所以去看看TED演讲吧。如果你喜欢，再去读那本书。我知道……你读了几个小时，所以去看看TED演讲吧，如果你喜欢，再去读那本书。我两样都做了，好吧，看了一半，读了全部，我是他的忠实粉丝。好了，我本周推荐的书是一本科幻小说，《童年的终结》，阿瑟·克拉克的经典科幻小说。下一本，它是经典吗？它是那种……
TED Talks, and they're both great. So, you know, the TED Talks take a total of, what, maybe 40 minutes, and the book would take, you know, a few hours. So watch the TED Talks. If you like them, read the book. I've know you know a few hours so watch the ted talks if you like them read the book i've done both well half of half of one and all of the other and i'm a big fan all right my book of the week is a science fiction book childhood and childhoods and arthur c clark classic science fiction book next is it a classic in the sense like is it from the
我不太清楚它具体是什么时候写的，但它绝对很复古，因为里面的科技，那种未来科技，真的……不是说可笑，但就是那种“哦，有趣，没错，他们当时还没有电脑屏幕”之类的。或者类似的东西，就像有人说用电报和卫星通话，你会觉得“什么？”，是的。所以，看那些老科幻作品真的很神奇，因为……比如我读过其中一本，也许……好吧，就像在《雪崩》里，你知道《雪崩》不算太老，尼尔·斯蒂芬森写的，但它……他们描述的东西基本上就是《第二人生》
uh i don't know exactly when it was from but it's definitely retro because the the technology the futuristic technology is really like uh not chuckle worthy but just kind of like like oh interesting that's right they didn't have like computer screens um yeah right or stuff like that right like oh you would use a you know it's like if someone said using the telegraph to talk to a satellite it's like what yeah um no yeah so yeah it's it's amazing watching like watching or reading like science fiction material that's old because uh like there's one of them i read maybe uh okay like in snow crash they uh which you know snow crash isn't that old neil stevenson but it uh it um they they describe this thing that is basically second life
但你知道，在当时这简直太疯狂、太离奇了，因为那是互联网出现之前。所以，是的，我不太谈论这本书，因为我从不知道在不剧透的情况下该说什么，但它很有趣，很吸引人，有点怪，但那种怪会让你思考，所以如果你没读过，一定要去看看。是的，绝对的。好了，现在是节目工具环节。我本周的工具是Uber。我第一次使用Uber，对于那些不知道它是什么的人，它是一个手机应用，你创建一个账户，关联你的信用卡或某种支付系统，我想他们现在也接受PayPal之类的。然后它提供出租车服务，而且
but uh you know just at the time it's just so crazy and outlandish because it's pre-internet you know so yeah i don't talk a lot about the book because i never know what to say without spoiling a fiction book but uh it's interesting it's intriguing it's kind of weird but like weird in a way that makes you think so you should check it out if you've never read it before yeah definitely all right so now tool of the show my tool of the show is uber i used uber for the first time for people who don't know what it is it is a phone app where you make an account you associate it with your credit card or some kind of payment system i think they're accepting like paypal and things like that now and then uh and then it does a taxi service and
它真的很棒。我快速讲讲我的经历。我的车坏了，我和我妻子把车拖到了修理厂。哦不，等等，抱歉。我的车坏了，但不是那次，我们一个月前也拖过一次车，但上次坏的时候，我们开着另一辆车去了修理厂，放下车，然后我妻子开车送我去上班。他们当天修好了车，所以我得自己回修理厂取车。于是我用了Uber。首先，你进入程序，因为你手机的GPS定位和
it's actually pretty amazing so i'll tell you my experience quickly. My car broke and my wife, we towed the car to the dealership. Oh no, wait, sorry. My car broke, but it didn't, we also had to tow it to the dealership a month ago, but the last time it broke, we, a different car, we drove it to the dealership, dropped it off, and then my wife drove me to work. They had it fixed, you know, at the end of the day, and so I had to get back to the car dealership by myself. So I took Uber. So first things first, you go into the program, because of your phone's GPS, location and
服务，它知道你在哪里，利用这些信息给你一张小地图，基本上显示：“这是我推测你所在的位置。你想在这里上车吗？”然后它会显示车型，给你一个车型列表。你可以输入是否需要婴儿座椅之类的。我只需要一辆普通的Uber，对吧？然后它会说：“好的，酷。你想去哪儿？”你在地图上找到目的地，它用起来就像……我想它用的是谷歌地图，非常直观。点击你的目的地，你也可以搜索它，然后它会给你一个价格预估。在我的案例中，预估非常准，他们给了一个范围，最后价格正好在中间。
services, it knows where you are, uses that information and it gives you a little map and basically says, here's where I think you are. Do you want to be picked up here? Then it shows you what kind of car, it gives you a list of car choices. And you can put in if you need a baby seat and things like that. I just need a regular Uber, right? So then it says, okay, cool. Where do you want to go? You find your destination on the map, which works just like, I think it uses Google Maps, but it just it's very intuitive right tap on your destination um you can also search for it and then um it'll give you an estimate of the price which in my case ended up being right on they gave me a range and ended up
而且它会告诉你司机还有多久到达，诸如此类。一旦你接受，它会在地图上显示司机的位置，甚至在他到达之前。所以你可以坐在那儿，盯着手机，被动地看着这个小吃豆人游戏上演，看着司机向你所在的位置移动。它还会显示司机的照片，所以你知道那是Uber司机来接你，而不是什么连环杀手，除非连环杀手戴着面具。然后
being right in the middle and um and then it tells you it will tell you how long before the driver gets there and and so on and so forth then as soon as you accept, it shows you the driver before he's even gotten to you on the map. So you can sit there on your phone and sort of passively watch this little Pac-Man game being played out where the driver makes his way over to where you are. It also shows you a picture of the driver so you know it's like an uber the guy picking you up and not some psycho killer unless the psycho killer has a mask then
司机接上你，把你送到目的地，你直接下车就行了，因为付款已经完成了。你不需要处理小费，不需要在钱包里翻找美元纸币什么的，直接走人就行。
the guy picks you up takes you to wherever your destination is and you just walk out like the payment's already done you don't have to deal with tip you don't have to fumble around in your wallet for dollar bills or anything you just walk out
我觉得整个过程太棒了，我强烈推荐。你没有那种尴尬感。你不需要在钱包里翻找美元纸币什么的。你直接走人。我觉得整个过程太棒了，强烈推荐。不错。我本周的工具是商店优惠券应用。省钱。别觉得尴尬。不用担心在出门前打印出来。排队等待时查一下就行。
I thought the whole thing was awesome and I highly recommend it You don't have that awkwardness. You don't have to fumble around in your wallet for dollar bills or anything. You just walk out. I thought the whole thing was awesome and highly recommend it. Nice. My tool of the show are store coupon apps. Save money. Don't be embarrassed. Don't have to worry about printing out before you leave. Just look it up while you're standing in line waiting.
搞定。商店优惠券应用。是的，在手机上下载你常去的商店的App，获取优惠券。举个例子，如果你去塔吉特（Target），塔吉特有个App，你下载它，里面就有优惠券。或者家得宝（Home Depot），我在家得宝排队时想：“嘿，不知道有没有优惠券。”我下载了家得宝App，果然有优惠券，我点一下，店员扫一下，我就省钱了。天哪，我竟然不知道。我发现这里的商店人非常多，尤其是下班后，因为大家想法都一样。所以排队时，我就顺便找找优惠券。我竟然不知道……所以我从没装过商店的……
Done. Store coupon apps. Yeah, download apps for a store you shop at on your phone and get the coupons like what's an example if you go to target target as an app you just download the target app and they got coupons or home depot i was at home depot i was standing in line saying hi i wonder if there's a coupon i downloaded the home depot app it's like sure enough here's a coupon i just click it and the person scans it and i save money holy cow i did not know so i spend i find that stores here can get very busy especially if you go right after work because everybody else has the same idea and so stand in line and while i'm standing in line i just cruise for coupons i did not know that the so i've never installed a store
我刚帮你省了钱。我竟然不知道他们有优惠券。天哪。你应该检查你去的每一家店。是的，我应该。我应该在手机上专门设一页。或者当你刚到商店，在停车场时，提前打开它，看看：“我需要这些东西，不知道有没有优惠券。”
i just saved you money i did not know that they had coupons. Oh, my gosh. You should check every store you go to. Yeah, I should. I should just have a page on my phone. Or right when you get to the store, you're in the parking lot. Just pull it up in advance and be like, here's the things I need. I wonder if there's anything.
哦，看那儿。天哪，太神奇了。哇。好吧，酷。这虽然很笼统，不具体，但我很高兴这对你有这么大的影响。我一定会那么做的。我一定会下载塔吉特和全食超市（Whole Foods）的App。是的，比如杂货店，Safeway也有一个。
Oh, yeah, look there. Oh, man, that is amazing. Wow. Okay, cool. That was very generic, nonspecific, but I'm glad this has such an impact on you. I will definitely do that. I will definitely get the Target app and the Whole Foods app. Yeah, so, like, the grocery store, Safeway, has one, too.
不同的店有不同的……有时候它们不一定是奖励计划，但当你扫描时，它们知道你……你可以把各种优惠券合并成一次扫描，你扫一下，所有适用的优惠券都会自动扣除，然后它还会为你推荐相关的新优惠券，对吧？这是它们让你回店消费的方式。但它们确实很有用，而且是我通常会去的店，所以我并不介意。是的，那太棒了，我一定会去看看。现在我们进入Haskell环节。Haskell是一种函数式编程语言。所以杰森，为什么不先给我们讲讲Haskell里的函数呢？
And different ones have, like, you know, sometimes they, like, you know, have, like, not, a not like a rewards program per se but kind of where like they they'll when you scan it they know what you you can have like various coupons collapsed into kind of one scan and you just scan it and all the coupons that apply it just takes them off and then it recommends new ones for you that are related right so that's their way to get you back to the store but yeah they tend to be pretty helpful and it's a store i already go to typically so i don't really mind yeah no that's awesome i'll definitely check it out so now we're on to haskell so haskell is a functional programming language so jason yeah real quick sorry to interject but before we before we before we dive into haskell i just want to give a shout out explanation no sorry the uh i know we said
好的。关于Haskell的函数，有一点是它们是“一等公民”。很多人不知道“一等公民”到底是什么意思。这是一个你常听到的术语，但没人真正定义过它，至少对我没定义过。这可能意味着我们对它的定义是错的。是的，所以当这种情况发生时，你通常会觉得：“哦，它意味着我有一个模糊的、不明确的概念。”但它其实很简单，在编程语言中成为一等公民只需要满足几点。第一，能够作为参数传递。换句话说，函数应该能够把这个东西当作参数。它应该能够从函数中返回，这
we'd do swift we'll definitely do swift. We'll definitely do Swift, but we got several requests over the week. We got a ton of requests, actually, over the week to do Haskell a lot. Yeah, well, every week. Especially this week, we got blasted to do Haskell. Ironically, we got requests to do Swift after we had decided we were going to
非常相似，而且它应该能够被赋值给变量。所以，如果你讨论的特定结构能做到这三件事，它就是一等公民。这就是为什么例如在Java中，类定义本身是一等公民，因为你可以把类类型作为函数参数传递给某个需要它的函数，对吧？但在C++中，类不是一等公民。我是说，类是，但类定义不是一等公民。没错。但类定义，比如方法名之类的，
abandon Swift for Haskell this week. It's sort of like, I don't know if people are messing with us, but anyways, that's why we're doing Haskell this week. So it's sort of like, I don't know if people are messing with us. Yes. But anyways, so that's why we're doing Haskell. Brace yourselves. Swift is coming. Swift is coming swiftly.
会被编译器移除。所以它不能成为一等公民。所以，是的，在Haskell中，函数是一等公民，这让你能构建有趣的东西，对吧？我以前使用函数作为一等公民的一个例子，或者仅仅是以有趣的方式使用函数，就是我曾多次实现过状态机。你知道，状态机，比较天真地
Yes. You completely botched my train. I had, like, an awesome transition, too. It was epic. Sorry. No, it's okay. So Haskell is a functional programming language. So Jason, why don't you start us off by telling us something about functions in Haskell?
人们倾向于……你第一次实现它的方式，有时也是正确的方式，就是用一个枚举，枚举包含了你所有的状态。然后每次更新时被调用的东西，会传入当前的条件，判断是否应该转换状态，这只是一个巨大的switch-case语句，对吧？根据状态，你有各种情况来处理从一个状态到另一个状态的转换。这会变得非常混乱。另一种方法是为每个状态使用单独的文件或
Okay. So one thing about Haskell's functions, they're first-class citizens. And a lot of people don't know what first-class citizens, what that really means. Like it's a term that you hear, but nobody ever really defines it, at least not to me. Which probably means we have wrong definitions. Yeah, so when that happens, you usually figure like, oh, it means that I have this vague, nebulous idea of what that means. But all that means, there's just a handful of things that you need to be a first-class citizen in a programming language. One is being able to be passed as a parameter. So in other words, like a function should be able to take this thing as an argument. It should be able to be returned from a function, which is
类来表示，然后你本质上持有一个指针，一个指向应该被调用的函数的变量。所以，“嘿，这是应该被调用的更新函数。”这也许不是一个完全能体现一等公民所有好处的例子。但如果你考虑指向函数本身，然后你可能会传入，“嘿，这是回调函数，我希望你在改变状态完成后调用它。”这就是你如何链接一系列事件来处理状态机，
very similar, and it should be able to be assigned to a variable. So if the particular construct you're talking about can can do those three things it's a first-class citizen. That's why for example in Java classes the actual class definition is a first-class citizen because you can actually pass the class type as a function parameter to some function that like needs that for for something very specific right but in C++, for example, classes are not first-class citizens. I mean, classes are, but class definitions are not first-class citizens. That's right. But a class definition, like the names of the methods and things like that,
而不需要一个巨大的switch-case语句。它允许你动态改变行为，所以你可以根据不同的情况重新配置状态转换。它允许你构建非常复杂的东西，而不会产生那种糟糕的意大利面条式代码。是的，是的，绝对的。关于Haskell的另一件事是，它是纯函数式的。
are removed by the compiler. And so it cannot be a first-class citizen. So, yep, in Haskell, functions are first-class citizens, which allows you to build interesting things, right? So one thing where I've used functions as first-class citizens before is, or just even, you know, kind of using functions in an interesting way, is several times I've implemented kind of like a state machine. And, you know, a state machine, kind of naively,
这意味着每个函数在给定相同的参数集时，会做完全相同的事情。没有你可以随意篡改的全局内存之类的东西。如果你用xyz调用一个函数，它每次都会返回abc。是的，是的，没错，这让人困惑，因为起初我以为你指的是名为xyz的变量。哦不，所以是的，如果你用一组特定的输入调用函数，你每次都会得到完全相同的输出。好吧，前提是它不是基于时间之类的东西。但绝对没有其他变量会影响你的函数。所以即使是“变量”这个概念，我觉得这有点难，我甚至还没触及函数式编程的皮毛。
people tend to, you know, kind of like the first way you ever implement it, and sometimes it's the right way, is you just have like an enumeration, and the enumeration has all your states. And then the thing that gets called each update or whatever gets passed in what the current conditions are and whether you should transition a state is just a big switch case statement, right? So on the state and you have various cases to handle moving from one to the other um and it gets really messy right another way to do it is to have separate files or
我还有很多要学，我一直在努力多学一点，因为我认为这对推理其他事情很有帮助。但在纯函数式语言中，连变量名都可能让人困惑，因为它并不是真正的“变量”。如果你说x等于5，x必须永远等于5，否则你就是在撒谎。所以你不能在后面改变x的值。如果你设定它是5，它就必须永远是5。所以……哦，你是说为什么要叫它变量？是的，它不是变量，变量意味着它会变。是的，它不能变。所以人们说“变量x等于……”，但它不是变量，它不能变。嗯，如果x等于一个基于文件输入或其他东西的函数呢？也许如果x等于一个函数，那它就能变，对吧？
classes to represent each of the states and then you essentially hold a pointer a variable that you know points to the class as the function that should be called. So, hey, here's the update that should be called. This is maybe not a completely great example of, like, all that effort being a first class citizen entails. But if you think about, you know, pointing to the function itself, and then you may pass in, hey, here's the function, like a callback function, I want you to call when you're done changing your state or whatever. And that's how you kind of link the series of events to handle the state machine
但如果你说x等于加法函数，它必须永远等于加法函数。即使它执行不同的加法，它仍然必须执行加法。哦，你是对的。那说得通。所以它确实颠覆了……函数式编程的替代方案通常被称为命令式编程。不同的加法，它仍然必须执行加法。哦，你是对的。是的，但其中一个……它确实颠覆了……函数式编程的替代方案通常被称为命令式编程。你知道，程序按第一行、第二行、第三行执行。所以它颠覆的一点是，当你不能随意改变状态时，你必须以不同的方式思考。
without having to have like a giant switch case statement. And it allows you to dynamically change the behavior so you can reconfigure what state transitions to which else based on something different. And it allows you to build up something really complex without having like really nasty spaghetti code. Yeah, yeah, definitely. So another thing about Haskell, it's pure.
当事情不会到处改变其他东西的状态时，如果你先学的是命令式编程，你就必须以不同的方式思考。关于哪种语言先学更容易，似乎存在争议。学习函数式编程很难吗？还是仅仅因为我们大多先学了非函数式语言，然后再尝试学习函数式？是的，我读过一篇有趣的文章，谈到了
What that means is each function will do exactly the same thing given the same set of parameters. There's no global memory that you can mess with or anything or anything or anything like that like if you call a function with xyz it will return abc every single time where yeah yeah yep that was confusing because at first i thought you meant variable named xyz oh no so yeah if you call a function with a certain uh set of inputs you will get exactly the same output every time. Well, provided that it's not based on time or something like that. But there's definitely no other variables that can affect your function. So even the notion, and I find this a little difficult, and I'm not even barely scratching the surface of functional programming.
函数式语言，以Excel电子表格为例。什么？是的，如果你看Excel电子表格，Excel就是一种函数式语言，因为如果你看Excel电子表格，每个单元格都包含其他单元格的函数，但没有顺序。所以它不是命令式的，对吧？你不是说“计算这个单元格，然后计算那个单元格”，你只是说“这个单元格基于其他单元格”，然后你依赖Excel以合理的顺序计算单元格的值。我想知道如果你在Excel里创建一个循环会发生什么？它可能只是……哦，它无法评估，它会放一个特殊的标志，基本上说出错了。就像……
I still have a lot to go, and I'm always trying to learn a little bit more because i think it's helpful in reasoning about other stuff but is that even the variable name can be confusing in a pure language because it's not really variable if you say x is equal to five um x always needs to be equal to five or else you're a liar um and so you can't change what x is equal to later on if you say it said it's five it needs to always be five um and so oh so you're saying why call it a variable yes it's not variable variable means it varies yeah it can't vary so people say the variable x is equal but it's well it's not a variable it can't vary um uh well what if x is equal to a function that was based on input from a file or something? Maybe if x is equal to a function, then it could vary, right?
因为你可以说a1等于b1加c1，b1等于a1加c1之类的，然后整个世界就崩溃了，或者如果只是a等于b，b等于a，如果你输入这个，我想你会得到所有错误。但无论如何，Excel是一个每个人都用过的函数式语言的完美例子。也许不是每个人，但你认为……我是说，这又是可以争论的，你认为什么才算“每个人”？我会认为……因为你想想，我敢肯定我们的父母也用Excel。我……好吧，你说得有道理。我只是在卖弄学问。我知道，但这很有趣，我想知道美国人或者西方人中，有多少比例……
But if you say x is equal to the function addition, it needs to always be equal to the addition function. Even if it does different addition, it still has to do addition. Oh, you're right. That makes sense. So it does turn it up on its... So the alternative to functional programming is typically called imperative programming. different addition it still has to do addition oh you're right yeah but one of the one so it does turn it up on its so the alternative functional programming is typically called imperative programming um you know things execute line one then line two then line three and so one of the things that turns on its head is the fact that you have to think about things
听这个播客的人可能使用Excel的概率很高。哦，是的，听这个播客的人可能接近100%。但无论如何，如果你想想Excel及其工作方式，那算是函数式语言的一个很好的入门，因为你只是把一堆函数放在各处，然后让Excel处理一切。拥有这种纯粹性的好处之一，或者说你想要这种纯粹性的原因之一，就是事情不会改变。你可以说如果x等于5，它就永远等于5。如果我传入某个值，没有副作用。所以如果我
differently when you can't just change the state willy-nilly as we'll say um and when things don't just go around changing what other things are, you have to kind of think about it differently if you first learned imperative. And there seems to be a debate about which one's easier to learn first. Is it hard to learn functional programming, or is it just because we mostly learn non-functional languages and then try to learn functional later? Yeah, I read this interesting article that talked about
有加法函数，我传入1和2，我永远会得到3。它允许你做一些在其他语言中没有大量限制就无法做到的事情，那就是对程序进行推理。所以如果我在Haskell中验证了1加1总是等于2，1加1等于2……我不需要一直用程序中变化的其他状态来检查它，因为它根本不存在。所以你可以对函数的正确性做出断言，编译器可以推理出东西会是什么，什么可以安全改变，什么不能改变。而如果你引用了一个全局变量，例如，
functional languages uh as using excel spreadsheets as an example what yeah if you look at an excel spreadsheet like excel is a functional language because if you look at an excel spreadsheet each of the cells contains a function of the other cells but there's no um order so it's not imperative right so you're not saying you know compute this cell and then compute that cell you're just saying this cell is based on these other cells and then you're relying on excel to to realize the value of the cells in an order that makes sense and like i think i wonder what happens if you create a loop in excel it probably just oh just yeah everything that's it can't it can't evaluate it puts like a special flag it basically says something's wrong like does not
它必须认为全局变量随时可能改变。因此，它无法推理该全局变量与函数其余部分之间的交互，而函数其余部分可能与该全局变量没有任何直接关系。没错。所以实际上，在Haskell中，你不需要定义大多数变量的类型，甚至可能所有变量都不需要。我想确实有一些非常特殊的情况，你在实践中几乎永远不会遇到，你需要指定类型。
because you could say like a1 equals b1 plus c1 and b1 equals a1 plus c1 or something and then just like the whole world falls apart or just a equals b and b equals a if you just put that in you get all errors i guess but at any rate so so excel is a perfect example of a functional language that everybody has used maybe not everybody but you don't think i mean like again this this is like debatable but what do you constitute as everybody i would consider i mean because you think about it i'm sure our parents use x no i i was okay yeah you have a fair point i i was just being pedantic i i think i know but i mean it's interesting i wonder what percentage of say americans or or let's say westerners we'll say
但在一般情况下，你不需要为任何东西指定类型，因为Haskell可以评估代码并算出它应该是什么类型。这是一个很好的过渡，引出Haskell的优势之一，即它的类型系统。是的，我的意思是，如果你想想Lisp、Prolog或其他函数式语言，它们大多是弱类型的。通常，像Lisp和Python这样的弱类型语言，很难扩展，对吧？因为会发生的情况是，你会遇到
people listening to this podcast probably have a pretty high chance of using some short oh yeah people listening to this podcast is probably close to 100 but yes but anyways so the uh so so if you think about excel and how it works that is sort of a good introduction to a functional language because you just put a bunch of functions all over the place and then you just let excel take care of everything and one of the happy benefits or one of the reasons why you would want to have this pureness where so getting uh the where things don't change right you can say that if x is equal to five it's always equal to five if i pass in some value there's no side effect so if i
编译时错误，直到运行时你才会发现。每当你遇到这种情况，你的生产力本质上就降低了。因为你必须实际部署某些东西，或者运行某种非常深入的模拟，才能找到一个强编译器语言会立即告诉你的错误。所以Haskell的美妙之处在于它是一种函数式语言，但它有一个强大的类型系统，可以捕获许多这些错误，让你更有效率。是的，类型系统允许静态类型，
have the function addition and i pass in one and two i will always get three is it allows you to do things that you can't always do without a very large set of restrictions in another language which are kind of reasoning about a program so if i validate that one plus one equal always equals two in haskell uh one plus one equals two ones right like i don't need to keep checking it with varying other states of the program because it's just not a thing. So you can say something about the correctness of a function and the compiler can reason about what stuff will be and what's safe to change or not change versus if you're referencing a global variable, for instance,
这样当你编译程序时，编译器可以推理对象的类型并为你进行类型检查，这样你就可以在编译时捕获许多错误。你会听到这个时髦的术语。关于Haskell有很多研究。这似乎成了一个笑话，你知道，Haskell只被研究人员使用。我不能……是的，就像编程语言编译器。是的。所以你会听到“Hindley-Milner类型推断”这个术语，你可以去读读它具体是什么。但它基本上给了你两件事。一是它定义了给定表达式可以具有什么类型的方法。
it has to believe that global variable could change at any time. And so it can't reason about the interaction of that global variable to the rest of the function that may have nothing to do with that global variable directly. That's right. So you can actually, in Haskell, you don't have to define the type of most of the variables, maybe even all of the variables. I think there's actually some very specific cases, which you'll almost never run into in practice, where you have to of the variables. I think there's actually some very specific cases which you'll almost never run into in practice where you have to specify the type.
然后是计算给定表达式类型的算法。所以这些东西加在一起非常强大。我经常听到人们说：“哦，Haskell的类型系统非常强大。”如果不真正深入了解，很难知道这意味着什么。但本质上，它是一种允许你编写函数和进行函数重载的方法。比如在C++中，你必须进行模板编程来处理泛型类型。所以Haskell允许你用某种方式说：“我有一个类型为a的项目，它是这个函数的输入，输出是一个类型为a的列表。”……一组类型为a的东西放在一起。它允许你做类似的事情并进行检查，
But in general, you don't have to specify the type for anything because Haskell can evaluate the code and figure out what type it should be. And that's a good transition into one of the strengths of Haskell, which is this type system. Yeah, I mean most of these, if you think about Lisp or Prolog or other functional languages, they're all weakly typed. And in general, weakly typed languages like Lisp and Python, it's just very hard to scale those, right? Because what will happen is you'll end up with
这是你在其他语言中也能做到的，但它恰好是它实现的方式。你可以在Haskell中定义一些东西，做非常有趣的事情。在我看来，就像在C++中一样，你可能会在模板编程中遇到很多问题。你可能会在
compile time errors that you won't catch until runtime. And whenever you have that situation, you're inherently less productive. Because you have to actually deploy something or run some kind of very in-depth simulation to find an error that a language with a stronger compiler would tell you immediately. So one of the beauties about Haskell is it's a functional language, but it has a strong type system that will catch a lot of these errors and let you be more productive. Yeah, and so the type system allows static typing
摆弄类型系统和在类型系统中做非常复杂的事情时陷入泥潭。Haskell有时对不熟悉它的人来说很难读，甚至对熟悉它的人来说也是如此，但类型系统似乎尤其复杂。我看着它，
so that when you compile your program, the compiler can reason about the type of an object and do type checking for you so you can catch a lot of errors at compile time. You'll hear this fancy term. So there's a lot of research around Haskell. It seems to be like kind of like a running joke that, you know, Haskell is only used by researchers. I can't. Yeah, like programming language compiler. Yeah. So one of the things you hear this Hindley Milner type inference, and you can go read about like what that is in very, very specifics. But it kind of gives you two things. One is it basically is a way, a method for defining what types a given expression can have.
我心想，我甚至不知道这在说什么。这是需要小心的地方。我……我看了看我上一家公司团队里的几个人，他们写了很多Haskell，遗憾的是我们最终把它扔掉了，因为没有其他人懂Haskell，我们最终不得不重写所有代码。这其实挺悲哀的，因为这有点伤他们的心。无论如何……但确实，其中一个大问题是，很难理解程序在做什么。但我认为，你知道，使用Unix也很难，但现在每个人都在用Unix。Windows里有一堆Unix，OSX是基于BSD构建的，对吧？所以，可能Haskell只是超前于它的时代，
And then algorithm for computing the type of a given expression and so these things together are really powerful and you hear about like i hear about this a lot that you know oh the type system in haskell is really strong and really powerful and without you know really getting into it it's hard to know what that means but essentially it's a way of allowing you to write functions and do function overloading so like in c++ you would have to do templated programming um to kind of handle generic types so haskell allows you kind of ways of saying i have an item a and is an input to this function and the output is a list of type a's um you know a set of type uh you know more than one of type a's together and allows you to do stuff like that and do checking,
不是有这种说法吗？也许吧，但我认为其中一部分也是因为人。所以这是同样的问题，这是我对Perl的看法。我对Perl本身没有意见，你知道，我没有强烈的偏见，但很多时候人们试图在Perl中做
which is something you can do in other languages, but it just happens to be the specific way that it's implemented and you're able to define stuff in Haskell that you can do very interesting things. And just in my opinion, that just like in C++, you can get into a lot of problems with templated programming. You can get into some really deep weeds with
疯狂的事情来炫耀。比如，“哦，我可以在Perl里用一行代码搞定这个。”你得到了经典的Perl单行代码。但它们根本无法理解。如果你只做一次，比如你试图清理一些输入文本，而且以后再也不会有人去碰它，那很好。你只是要把结果存在某个地方，
playing with the type system and doing really complex things in a type system in Haskell. Haskell can be sometimes hard to read for people who aren't familiar with it, or even sometimes are, but the type system especially seems just like a lot of it. I look at it
其他人会使用清理后的结果。那当然很好，没问题，去炫耀吧。但如果你要提交需要维护的代码，最好还是稍微啰嗦一点，把它写出来。有些人会反驳，这是我最近在团队中经常进行的辩论，有些人说：“哦不，最好做这些我称之为‘聪明’的事情。”人们很多时候这样做是为了炫耀，使用那些不常用的东西。而且它们在做什么并不总是显而易见的，因为这减少了代码行数。
and I'm just like, I don't even know what this is saying. It's something to be careful about i uh i looked at you know a couple people on the my team at the last place i worked wrote a bunch of haskell and sadly we ended up throwing it away because nobody else knew haskell and we ended up having to rewrite it all which is which is actually pretty sad because it kind of hurt their feelings anyways um but uh but yeah i mean that was one of the big things was that it was just very hard to understand what the program was doing but i think that you know it was also very hard to use unix but now everyone's using unix like windows has a bunch of unix in it osx is built on bsd right so so you know, it might be that Haskell is just before its time, like,
他们说理由是每一行代码都是潜在的Bug。所以你写的代码行数越少，Bug就越少。我想……我不知道，也许吧。好吧，是的，我认为你必须考虑Bug密度，对吧？是的，问题在于我无法快速推理你的代码。如果你写得更啰嗦，我能快速推理它，
isn't that the phrase? Maybe, yeah, but I think some of it also is people, so this is the same problem, so this is my issue with Perl, is I have no problem with Perl specifically, like, you know, I don't have strong feelings either way, but a lot of times people try to do
我就更有可能帮你捕获错误。如果你写了一些我不确定在做什么的代码，我更有可能拒绝它或者忽略它。我想说我会拒绝它，但现实是，有时你时间紧迫，有很多事情要处理。所以有时你会让一些东西溜过去，就像，如果你知道他们想做什么，你就不会让它通过，你会意识到那是个问题。
crazy stuff in Perl to kind of show off. So like, oh, I can do this in one line in Perl, right? And you get the classic Perl one-liners. But they're impossible to understand. Like, that's great if you're doing something once, one time, like you're trying to clean up some input text and no one will ever try to do it again. You're just going to store that result somewhere
是的。是的。所以这不是关于Haskell的对话，这有点跑题了。是的。不，但说到你的观点，我认为函数式语言通常需要更多的文档。因为它们声称自己比实际情况要简洁得多。而在Java中，也许你知道，每个文件写一个注释还可以。在Haskell中，100行代码可能实际上做了很多事情，你绝对应该在注释中非常啰嗦。所以我有点……这总是很难界定，
and everybody else will use the cleaned result. Like, sure, great, fine, show off. but if you're going to like be submitting code that's going to be maintained like it's better to be a little bit more verbose and write it out and you know some people argue back so this is a constant debate i was having recently on my team is that some people say oh no it's better to do these i call them clever things uh People a lot of times do it to try to show off like using things which aren't always commonly used. And it's not always immediately obvious what they're doing because it reduces line of code count.
但人们试图解释概念，有时试图通过过程有多详细或复杂来炫耀。但我个人并不喜欢那种风格。我更喜欢如果你能简短地向我解释，并且让我奶奶都能听懂，那你就比那些只会用更多流行语的人做得更好。而且我认为，作为行业，是的，Haskell可能有它的用途，但有时你会遇到一些狂热分子，他们喜欢它非常排他，喜欢那种经历痛苦的过程，但这并不总是事实。有时它确实是一个很好的工具，
And the reason they say is because every line of code is a potential bug. So the less lines of code you write, the less bugs you might you will have. I guess that I don't know, like maybe. Well, yeah, I think you have to think about bug density, right? Yeah, so that's the problem is like, I can't reason about your code quickly. If you wrote it out more verbosely and I can reason about it quickly,
适合这项工作。正如我所说，我从学习函数式编程中获得的好处之一，就是一种思考事物的新方式。有时，就像我们谈到的，处理不同状态机的方式。有时你不会在函数式编程语言中实现它，但你会带走一些概念。这真的很有帮助。没错。是的，我的意思是，你可以把很多函数式思想带入其他语言。比如在Java中，你可以有类实现某个接口，而接口中只有一个函数。
I'm more likely to help you catch errors. I'm more likely to either reject or gloss over if you write some line of code that I'm not exactly sure what it's doing. I would like to say that I reject it, but reality is sometimes you're pressed for time and you've got a lot of stuff to go through. And so sometimes you let something slip through and it's like, if you had known what they were trying to do, you wouldn't have let it, like you would have realized it was a problem.
我更有可能帮你发现错误。如果你写了一些我不太确定其作用的代码，我更有可能拒绝或者直接略过。我想说我会拒绝它，但现实情况是，有时你时间紧迫，有很多事情要处理。所以有时你会让一些问题溜过去，就像是，如果你当时知道他们想做什么，你就不会放过它，你会意识到那是个问题。
Yeah. Yeah. So this is not a conversation on Haskell. This is a little bit of a sidetrack. Yeah. No, but to your point though, I think functional languages in general require a lot more documentation. Because they make the claim that they're much less verbose than they are. whereas in java maybe you know a comment per uh file is okay in haskell where a you know like 100 lines could actually be doing quite a lot you should definitely be very verbose in your commenting so i kind of have so and this is always like something that's a little hard to pin down
是的。是的。所以这不是关于Haskell的对话。这有点跑题了。是的。不，但说到你的观点，我认为函数式语言通常需要更多的文档。因为它们声称自己比实际情况要简洁得多。而在Java中，也许你知道每个文件写一条注释就可以了，但在Haskell中，你知道，100行代码实际上可能做了很多事情，你绝对应该在注释中非常详细，所以我有点，而且这总是有点难以确定。
but um people try to explain concepts and sometimes try to show off by how like uh detailed or complicated the process is but i actually think that's kind of like i don't personally care for that style i prefer that if you could explain it to me shortly and in a way that like my grandma could understand it right like then you've done a better job than a person who can use more buzzwords um and so and i think sometimes that you know as an as an industry, yeah, there might be uses for Haskell, but sometimes you get people who are just fanatic about it and they like the fact that it's very exclusive and that, you know, it, you know, they can go through kind of the pain of doing it, but that's not always the case. Sometimes it is, it is really a good tool for
但是，人们试图解释概念，有时试图通过展示过程有多详细或复杂来炫耀，但我实际上认为这有点，我个人并不喜欢那种风格，我更喜欢如果你能简短地向我解释，并且以我奶奶能听懂的方式，对吧，那么你比一个只会用更多流行语的人做得更好。而且我认为有时，你知道，作为一个行业，是的，Haskell可能有其用途，但有时你会遇到一些对此非常狂热的人，他们喜欢它非常排他性的事实，而且，你知道，他们可以经历那种痛苦的过程，但这并不总是事实。有时它确实是一个很好的工具。
the job. And like I said, one of the benefits I've gotten from learning functional, trying to learn functional programming more and more, I won't say I have learned it, is a new way of thinking about things. And sometimes, like we were talking about, you know, the way of doing different state machines. Sometimes you don't implement it in a functional programming language, but you take some concept with you. That's really helpful. Exactly. Yeah, I mean, you can get a lot of functional ideas into other languages. Like with Java, you could have classes where the class implements some interface, and the interface only has one function in it.
对于这项工作。就像我说的，我从学习函数式编程，尝试越来越多地学习函数式编程中获得的好处之一，我不会说我已经学会了，是一种思考事物的新方式。有时，就像我们谈到的，你知道，实现不同状态机的方式。有时你不会用函数式编程语言来实现它，但你会带走一些概念。这真的很有帮助。没错。是的，我的意思是，你可以将许多函数式思想引入其他语言。就像在Java中，你可以拥有类，其中类实现某个接口，而该接口中只有一个函数。
And now you basically have function pointers in Java. So one thing to take away is that every language you learn sort of helps you holistically become a better programmer. Yep, yep, yep, yep. Cool, so can you explain what a monad is? Otherwise, you aren't a true programmer. Yep. Cool. So can you explain what a monad is? Otherwise you aren't a true Haskellite. No, I'm not a true Haskellite. I failed that test.
现在你基本上可以在 Java 中使用函数指针了。所以要记住的一点是，你学习的每一种语言都能从整体上帮助你成为一名更好的程序员。是的，没错。酷，那你能解释一下什么是单子（monad）吗？否则你就不是一个真正的程序员。是的。酷。那你能解释一下什么是单子吗？否则你就不是一个真正的 Haskell 程序员。不，我不是一个真正的 Haskell 程序员。我没通过那个测试。
I think it's hard to explain what monads are because it's a complicated concept. But I will try one way that I've begun to think about it. And I'm by no means, no I won't even say, I'm not even a monad beginner. And so there's probably people who could give us a better explanation. If you have a great explanation that you can send us that short, send it to us and we'll read it on
我觉得很难解释什么是单子，因为它是一个复杂的概念。但我会尝试用一种我开始思考它的方式来解释。我绝不是，我甚至不会说，我甚至连单子初学者都算不上。所以可能有人能给我们更好的解释。如果你有一个很棒的解释可以发给我们，而且很简短，请发给我们，我们会在节目中读出来
air and give you credit. And if my grandma, if I can reach to my grandma and she understands it, uh, you will probably win some sort of Nobel prize. I'm not sure in what. So if you think about a function, right, like a function is some way of doing computation, a notation for how to define like this thing is going to take some input, produce some output, and here's what it will do. And in Haskell, you can't have any side effects in your traditional functions. So if you think about a function being very strict in scope, and you think about something that's more general than a function, that can have notation that says other things besides I have an input, some code you're going to execute in an output, and here's maybe the types, but like you want to be able to have
并给你署名。如果我奶奶，如果我能联系到我奶奶，而她能听懂的话，呃，你可能会赢得某种诺贝尔奖。我不确定是什么奖。所以如果你思考一个函数，对吧，函数是一种进行计算的方式，一种定义如何进行计算的符号，即这个东西将接收一些输入，产生一些输出，这就是它要做的事情。在 Haskell 中，你的传统函数不能有任何副作用。所以如果你认为函数的作用域非常严格，并且你考虑一种比函数更通用的东西，它可以使用符号来表示除了“我有一个输入，一些你要执行的代码，一个输出，以及可能的类型”之外的其他事情，但你想要能够拥有
kind of almost other tags or syntactic sugar or things that you want to be able to have kind of almost other tags or syntactic sugar or things that you want to be able to say more about a function than just those things. Like you may want to say this thing does input or output. This has, this could raise an exception that it sometimes doesn't produce any result at all. If you want to say things at a higher level than just take some input, do some computation, produce want to say things at a higher level than just take some input do some computation produce some output and and reason at a higher level about what the function is going to do that's kind of what monads are are able to do for you okay this probably i i think that's that's how i'm currently understanding it so the classic one in haskell is is for input and output so if
几乎是其他的标签或语法糖，或者你想要能够拥有几乎是其他的标签或语法糖，或者你想要能够对函数说出比这些东西更多的事情。比如你可能想说这个东西执行输入或输出。这可能引发一个异常，有时它根本不产生任何结果。如果你想在比“接收一些输入，进行一些计算，产生一些输出”更高的层面上表达事情，并从更高的层面推理函数将要做什么，这就是单子能为你做的事情。好吧，这可能是我目前对它的理解。所以 Haskell 中经典的例子是用于输入和输出，所以如果
you want to write to the screen, you can't do that in a normal function. So you have a monad, which allows you to say, hey, I have some code that's going to run. If I'm also going to do other stuff, like I'm going to have input and output, I'm going to write to the screen. I might pause, things like that.
你想写入屏幕，你在普通函数中是做不到的。所以你有一个单子，它允许你说，嘿，我有一些代码要运行。如果我还要做其他事情，比如我要进行输入和输出，我要写入屏幕。我可能会暂停，诸如此类的事情。
And so that informs the compiler that, like hey something different than the rest of the program is going to happen here uh and things that interact with it it knows how to kind of think about those oh i see what you're saying so it's a it's a it's a way yeah i still gotta wrap my head around and i haven't fully either and i think there's many things it can be used for um but you know it's kind of a way of calling out that here is something that is going to have a side effect without just making the whole program basically say might have side effects so you're saying here's things which can produce side effects but the other things don't right like so gotcha anyways that's probably a poor explanation but i tried okay no i
这会通知编译器，嘿，这里将发生一些与程序其余部分不同的事情，并且与它交互的事物知道如何思考这些事情。哦，我明白你的意思了，所以这是一种……是的，我还在努力理解，我也还没完全理解，我认为它可以用于很多事情，但你知道，这是一种指出“这里有一些会产生副作用的东西”的方法，而不是让整个程序基本上都说“可能会有副作用”。所以你是说这里有一些可以产生副作用的东西，但其他东西不会，对吧？明白了。总之，这可能是一个糟糕的解释，但我尝试了。好吧，不，我
i think it makes sense i mean it's one of these things where i think i have to like have it explained to me many times and then each time i'll pick a little facet of the yeah i'm in the same boat and i'm still beginning my journey of understanding it so lazy evaluation so yeah another thing has to has is lazy evaluation and so again just think about say the excel example right let's say there's some cells that are way off the table like like your screen is like you're looking at cells a to g and rows 1 to 10 or 1 to 30 on your screen but if you were to scroll way down to you know row 15 million there would be some data there right but obviously you know if you tell excel like add columns a and b it's not going to add the infinite number of rows of a and b together right like it's going
我觉得这说得通。我的意思是，这是那种我认为我必须让别人向我解释很多次，然后每次我都会领悟到它的一点点侧面的事情。是的，我和你一样，我还在理解它的旅程中。那么惰性求值（lazy evaluation），是的，Haskell 必须具备的另一件事是惰性求值。所以，再次考虑 Excel 的例子，对吧？假设有一些单元格在表格之外，比如你的屏幕上显示的是 A 到 G 列，第 1 到 10 行或 1 到 30 行，但如果你滚动到第 1500 万行，那里会有一些数据，对吧？但显然，如果你告诉 Excel 把 A 列和 B 列相加，它不会把 A 列和 B 列的无限行加在一起，对吧？它会
to probably just add what you have on your screen and maybe like some of the border and as you scroll around excel will will start filling in cells that it didn't know before right like it still knows how to compute them but it's not going to compute them because you're not looking at them yep right and it knows how it may have to compute some of them because you may have a cell on your screen that references some of them and so it'll go compute those but the ones that you don't care about have no reference reference to right now, it won't do. Exactly. There's got to be some way to really screw with Excel.
可能只是把你屏幕上有的加起来，也许还有一些边界，当你滚动时，Excel 会开始填充它之前不知道的单元格，对吧？它仍然知道如何计算它们，但它不会计算它们，因为你没有在看它们。是的，对吧？它知道它可能必须计算其中一些，因为你屏幕上的某个单元格可能引用了它们，所以它会去计算那些，但你现在不关心的那些没有引用的，它就不会做。没错。一定有什么方法可以真正搞乱 Excel。
I'm sure people have done this, like crazy Excel hacks where it just locks your computer. You open a spreadsheet and your whole computer locks up or something. Anyway, so this is lazy evaluation. Haskell does this as well. So if they might define a function or a set of functions over a space, but they're not
我相信人们已经做过这种事了，比如疯狂的 Excel 黑客攻击，让你的电脑死机。你打开一个电子表格，然后你的整个电脑就锁死了之类的。总之，这就是惰性求值。Haskell 也这样做。所以如果他们可能在一个空间上定义一个函数或一组函数，但他们不会
going to instantiate every possible one of them. They're going to at runtime start realizing the values of the outputs of functions as you need. Which leads you to weird things like infinite lists, which, okay, and church encodings, which I tried to understand and I still don't understand.
实例化每一个可能的函数。他们会在运行时根据需要开始实现函数输出的值。这会导致一些奇怪的事情，比如无限列表，好吧，还有丘奇编码（church encodings），我试着去理解，但仍然不明白。
I've never heard of, I'll have to research that one. This is the story of my Haskell life, like researching one thing after another. But like I said, you learn. So we have some resources for getting started real quick. Learn You a Haskell for Great Good. This is a very interesting approach to a programming language book uh and it's you can either buy the dead tree version or
我从来没听说过，我得研究一下那个。这就是我的 Haskell 生活的故事，就像研究一件又一件事情。但正如我所说，你会学到的。所以我们有一些快速入门的资源。《Learn You a Haskell for Great Good》。这是一种非常有趣的编程语言书籍方法，你可以购买纸质版或者
read it online um and it's pretty good i didn't make it all the way through i kind of it's one of those things like haskell's uh complexity curve is very exponential so you read early and it's like oh it's too slow too slow too slow so you just kind of start skipping and you're like oh wow i have no idea what's going on it's like, oh, it's too slow, too slow, too slow. So you just kind of start skipping and you're like, oh, wow, I have no idea what's going on. It's definitely not like linear. So there's also learn Haskell fast and hard, which has an interactive component to it, which I was playing with earlier today in preparation. So I think I'm gonna have to check that out a little more, too. Oh, cool. Very cool.
在线阅读，它相当不错。我没有完全读完，它属于那种 Haskell 的复杂度曲线呈指数级上升的书，所以你读得早的时候会觉得“哦，太慢了，太慢了，太慢了”，所以你开始跳过，然后你会觉得“哦，哇，我完全不知道发生了什么”。它绝对不是线性的。所以还有《Learn Haskell Fast and Hard》，它有一个交互式组件，我今天早些时候为了准备节目玩了一下。所以我认为我也得再多看看那个。哦，酷。非常酷。
Yeah, this is awesome. So definitely check it out. Haskell, it's getting a lot of popularity, and it's very forward-thinking. Right now, programming language geeks like it, but as you said, Unix geeks were the only people who liked Unix, and now everyone's running it in some form or another. So yeah, it was great doing the show on Haskell. It's been long overdue, and we look forward to doing some Swift next time.
是的，这太棒了。所以一定要去看看。Haskell 正在获得很多关注，而且它非常有前瞻性。现在，编程语言极客喜欢它，但正如你所说，Unix 极客是唯一喜欢 Unix 的人，而现在每个人都在以某种形式运行它。所以，很高兴能做这期关于 Haskell 的节目。这期节目早就该做了，我们期待下次做一些关于 Swift 的内容。
Alright, until next time. See you later. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit
好的，下次见。再见。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的《Axo》。Programming Throwdown 是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下发布的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播
the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
该作品，进行重混、改编，但你必须注明我和 Patrick 的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。